albert le floch et guiraud par croit que
les problèmes de vision des dyslexiques
vient du fait qu'il n'aurait pas de est
dominant les deux chercheurs ont voulu
savoir ce qui causait cette absence de
vision dominante
ils sont allés voir ce qui se passait
dans les yeux des participants
et s'intéresse un endroit bien précis de
la forêt à
celle qu'on appelle la tâche de maxwell
cette tâche minuscule contient les
photorécepteurs jouerait un rôle clé
dans la cuite et visuels pour l'observer
ils ont créé cet appareil le fovéa scop
les participants qui regarde à
l'intérieur voix lors des filtres vert
et bleu
après quelques secondes d'observation
une tache sombre apparaît c'est la tâche
de maxwell
les participants sont invités à dessiner
son contour la plupart vont dessiner les
tâches asymétrique ronde dans un oeil et
difforme dans l'eau les chercheurs sont
convaincus que cette asymétrie est
importante elle permettrait d'identifier
les dominants sans compter que on a
également trouvé que l'oeil dominant
comme par hasard qu correspond à lorsque
la tâche de maxwell et bien ronde bien
bien délimitées c'est celui là le domine
tout le temps la dominance de la veille
semble être liée à l'aide à la
topographie déconne au fond de nos
chacune de nos fauves et lorsque 27 des
30 participants dyslexiques dessinent
leur tâche de maxwell surprise il
dessine devront parfaitement circulaires
il n'ya pas d'asymétrie donné à l'autre
donc là c'est pareil c'est la même
géométriques le droit de lancer une
circulaire c'est leur principale
découverte les tâches de maxwell serait
symétrie chez les personnes dyslexiques
les chercheurs concluent que les
dyslexiques non pas un mais deux yeux de
millions